You're looking at this and going, "Wow! Wouldn't it be amazing if this worked."
And then you realize, "Oh my gosh, it does work!"
National borders are just speed bumps
in the information superhighway.
Cryptography is really, really strong.We can do whatever we want here.
It might provide the equivalent of whatgovernment does in a decentralized fashion.
I talk about collapse of governments. I thinkwe actually saw that in the Middle Ages,
probably as a result of the printing press.
This is the story of a community of scientists,mathematicians, philosophers, and activists
who believe that the internet combined with recentbreakthroughs in the field of cryptography
would upend society and usher in anew era of sovereign individualism.
We have it in our power to beginthe world over again right now.
And its internal clash over theoptimal path to achieving that goal.
Can evil be done with this technology? Yes.
And so, what?
Deal with it.
Here's the final installmentin a four-part series
on the origins of the cypherpunk movement andhow it helped shape our modern world.
We see a free world that hasachieved a level of prosperity unprecedented in all human history.
Mr. Gorbachev, tear down this wall!
If you had asked me 10 yearsago, "is it possible thatcommunism could collapse by the year 1992,"
I would've said, "absolutely ridiculous."
The fall of the Berlin Wall was important to mebecause I thought it was the end of history
and that national borders would cease being the wallsof prisons.
And so, a couple years later, when I discovered the internet, I thought,
"Oh, this is part of this pattern where borders and distance stop being barriers to people."
Then I discovereda whole clan of people who self-identified ascomputer people.
I found my tribe. And amongthat clan was the cypherpunks mailing list.
If you want to subscribe to our mailing list,send a blank email message and just say subscribe cypherpunks.
And what is a cypherpunk?What do you guys stand for? Cypherpunks are cryptography activists.
The cypherpunks email list, whichstarted in the fall of 1992,
one year after the launch of the World Wide Web,became a gathering place for a global community
interested in using cryptography to allowindividuals to communicate and transact on the internet privately
and withoutinterference from a central authority.
In the last 20 years, the basic techniquesto do all sorts of impossible-seeming things have suddenly emerged.
Put them into practice.
Many cypherpunks were inspired by the workof the computer scientist David Chaum,
who had demonstrated that it was possibleto use cryptography
to build an anonymous payment network that ran on the internet.
Because of the cypherpunks and because of thescience papers of David Chaum,
I thought the third thing that's going to happen is economic freedom.
That people are going to be no longer constrainedby national borders and distance
from cooperatingand sharing resources and helping each other.
But at this watershed moment of collapsingborders, there was a divide within the cypherpunk community
over whether these cryptographic toolswould lead to more individual freedom, free trade,
and the spread of democracy, or the end of
government altogether.
The cypherpunk movement's most influential figure was the physicist andintellectual provocateur Tim May,
who coined the phrase 'crypto anarchy.'
He saw the fall of the Berlin wall as evidence that the societal institutions we take for granted could collapse in short order,
just as they had in the Middle Ages.
We saw the little principalities,the monarchies, the religious,the papal states,
we saw those collapseprobably as a result of publishing, printing.
May penned a one-page summary of how cryptography would upend society.
So I just sat down at my littleMacintosh and loosely patternedthis after the Communist Manifesto.
"A specter is haunting the modernworld, the specter of crypto-anarchy."
Cryptography is really, really strong. We can be protected from anything without, from
the observers, from the watchers, from the imposers ofthe past, upon the future we're trying to create.
May was skeptical of the idea that humanity waswitnessing an unabashed victory of economic and political liberalism
or that it was possibleto overcome tyranny through collective action.
As the political scientistFrancis Fukuyama argued,
"We as human beings want to berecognized with a certain dignity.
This is the essential driving forcebehind democratic revolutions,
whether they take place in EasternEurope or in Asia or in Latin America."
May embraced a technology-based theory of historicchange summed up by the movement's tagline,
which was coined by the mathematicianEric Hughes, "cypherpunks write code."
What Eric meant by "cypherpunks write code" is don't be one of those guys who goes to a Libertarian Party conference
and sits aboutgetting somebody elected to the Los GatosCity Council.
That way lies madness.
Whereas the interesting things that hadhappened had been technological changes,
the telephone, copy machine, the VCR,
the thing that I really got interested in is thatyou don't just go and ask the regulator,
"Oh, we need more privacy online.' We go fix it.Arguing and complaining and lobbying and politics have nominal effects.
And what changes theworld is technology adoption and society moving,shifting its viewpoints.
For crypto-anarchists like May, writing codemeant building systems for anonymous transactions on the internet.
It made the arbitrarydivisions of the political world irrelevant.
National borders are just speed bumpson the information superhighway.
Online cryptographic networks wouldbe structured like a geodesic dome,
a form hailed by the counter-culturaltechnologists of the 1970s for being inharmony with nature
and highly resistant to external attack.
Networks with no owners with many interconnectingnodes that would be basically unstoppable.
In a geodesic market, "economicswill no longer be the handmaidenof politics,"
the cyberpunk writerRobert Hettinga noted.
"Nation-states will eventually be as ceremonial asmodern-day constitutional monarchs."
This idea of a many-to-many connection
was clearly going to happen.
But it was much easier to build afunctional network for cooperation and trade
when you can rely on a central authority to enforce the rules.
How could we use this weird crypto technique tosolve this strange, esoteric little problem that
in the real world you just solve because, "Oh,I know what your social security number is,"
or you have to have your government-issued IDthat you take to the bank so that you can open up your bank account,
and they can link the twotogether and say, "Okay, if Jim McCoy walks outon this $100,000 loan,
well, we know where to findhim." It was trying to deal with those problems.
You can buy and sell property incyberspace using cryptographic protocols.
The idea of ways in which people mightprovide the equivalent of what governmentdoes in a decentralized fashion.
Timstole some ideas from my Machinery ofFreedom
and he reprocessed them with all thistechnological stuff, and then I stole them back.
A function of government that was particularlyhard to replicate using cryptography was the issuance of money.
The cypherpunks attempted tobuild a borderless internet currency system asanonymous as cash,
and that like gold, held itsvalue without the backing of a central bank.
Gold makes very good moneybecause nobody can manufacture more of it very readily, to put it mildly.
Right? Whereas bits are perfectly copyable, so turning bits into goodmoney is quite difficult.
Tim May and many others consideredelectronic cash to be the holy grailbecause it completed the picture.
A private and decentralizedmonetary system, May argued,
was a key component in constructing a newborderless world where the activities
and assets of individuals would be resistantto government control and confiscation.
You don't physically meet theperson, if you don't even knowwhat continent they're on you can't coerce them.
But there was another faction withinthe movement that rejected Tim May'svision of cordoning off a new world in cyberspace.
The High-Tech Hayekians were people like
Eric Drexler, Mark Miller, Phil Salin.
They were focused on designing secure computingsystems based on economic insights,
particularly those of the Austrian-born Nobel Prize winnerFriedrich Hayek.
Instead of building a new virtual world shielded from government interference,
the High-Tech Hayekians sought to use technology to demolish walls and divisions within the existing world.
They imagined that introducing new toolsfor human coordination
would gradually erode the government's ability to impinge on our freedoms.
We did lots and lots of fantasizingabout how the world could be different,but we saw this as emerging from inside the world.
Cryptography was a tool for porting economicconcepts and legal structures onto the internet.
But the aim was to foster new forms ofpeer-to-peer commerce and knowledge sharing.
And the High-Tech Hayekians believed that evenimperfect systems can transformsociety gradually from within.
The overall arc of world history is towards
rule of law, towards less corruptible systems.
If the emergence of the world of crypto-commerce creates systems that are vastly less corruptible,
but under a whole mix of differentmechanisms and governance regimes such that
they're not always everywhereincorruptible, I think that's fine.
There's a lot of power in providing peopletools such that they can successfully startto act more like you would like them to.
As opposed to, "You've got to come over here where it's really hard edge encrypted andit works exactly the way we want."
No no, let's raise people's levels incrementally,and that's an improvement in the world.
For many cypherpunks the darker side of crypto-anarchy was epitomized by the writings
of a chemist and electrical engineer Jim Bell,a participant on the email list,
who in the mid-nineties compared aggression by the state tothat of muggers, rapists, robbers, and murderers,
and posited a cryptographically protectedmarketplace in which anonymous individuals could in effect,
pay to have government employeeskilled with the goal of destroying the state.
In 1997, Bell was arrested and wentto prison for, among other things,
dropping a stink bomb on a government building.
Tim May distanced himself from Bell's writings and activities while maintainingthat marketplaces for assassination,
like the one Bell had described, mightbe both inevitable and desirable.
Can evil be done withthis technology? Not just the internet, but especially the crypto part of it? Yes.
And so what?
Deal with it.
Zimmerman once told me thathe sometimes regretted ever introducing PGP to the world
because it could be usedby Al-Qaeda or the Taliban or whatnot.
I say, so what? I'm not morally responsible.
It would have happened whether we had existed or not.
Because technology has its own logic?
And people want to do what theywant to do. I mean, they want free sh*t.
They want freedom to do things. Even if they say that it should be regulated, they'll often make the conscious decision to copy music,
copy videotapes they want to see.
BlackNet is a negative consequence. I'm not
interested in creating that.
When you build technology to solve problems, then you create— then there are consequences that we try to think ahead of,
and look at, and figure out how we might address,
and get ahead of the downsides of what webuild, and that's responsible development.
And wecertainly engaged in that. And talking with TimMay and putting on that
"What if I was a blackhat" kind of thing was certainly a useful foil
for working through those kinds of ideas, but that's absolutely not what cypherpunks were.
So the progress of the spread of democracy,
if you take a sufficiently long-term viewof it, has been really quite remarkable.
Our dream was to enable thefuture of human freedom,
and we had this bizarre confidence about how the future would unfold,
and to use Alan Kay's famous phrase, have a huge hand in inventing it.
But the road had a lot more weeds anddetours than we could have anticipated.
When we first launched, we werehoping for maybe 400, 500 people.
Now we're at 100 thousand people.So who knows where we're going next?
Using the ever-growing storage capacity ofservers belonging to companies like Google.
Instead of it being on your server under yourdesk, that stuff is being taken of for you.
Professionals keep track ofall the programs and the data. Who doesn't want a simpler life? Ifind this way of working more simple.
You collect half a gigabyte of information on yourcustomers. What do you do with that information?
They want to know everything about youso they can sell your stuff.
And it resultsin you each getting a digital proctology exam. The NSA specifically targetsthe communications of everyone.
Over the next quarter-century, the internetwould make possible an explosion
of individual freedom and information sharing,just as Phil Salin had predicted in 1991.
But it would also grow into a surveillanceapparatus that bore out the dystopian vision
of journalist David Burnham in his 1983book, The Rise of the Computer State.
"Large bureaucracies with the power that the computer gives them become more powerful
and they are escaping the checks andbalances of representative democracy."
Facebook collects information that theEast German Stasi would have killed for.
I think that most people are quite happy to handpeople all of the information about them online
in return for a few pics of your highschool friends, kids, or whatever.
By the mid-2000s, it seemed the cypherpunkmovement had mostly failed.
Then came a global financial crisis followed by massivebailouts by central banks.
On October 31st, 2008, a pseudonymous inventor named SatoshiNakamoto shared a white paper
describing a new peer-to-peer, non-governmental monetary system,pulling together technical and philosophical concepts
developed on the Cypherpunks' email list.
Within a few years, the movement was reborn with a new generation
committed to enhancing personal freedom and privacy with cryptographic tools.
It's like discovering an oasiswhen you're lost in the desert.
It's bitcoin that's single-handedly responsiblefor the current wave of cypherpunk activity.
It's always messier than visionaries cananticipate because reality is bigger than any one head.
We're still on the road in thequest to build architectures that amplifyhuman freedoms
and protect us fromthe dynamics in the other direction.